bien entreprendre des rénovations peut
coûter cher mais si vous habitez sur le
plateau mont royal
attention la facture pourrait coûter
très très cher certains résidants vont
devoir débourser des dizaines de
milliers de dollars de plus à cause d'un
nouveau règlement de l'arrondissement
françois cormier daniel mayet habite le
plateau mont royal depuis 25 ans sa
conjointe et lui ont décidé de rénover
leur maison
ça serait d'éliminer le mur arrière ici
pour ce soit uniquement des fenêtres
mais lorsqu'il a voulu obtenir son
permis
mauvaise surprise il s'est fait dire
qu'il devrait payer à l'arrondissement
25 à 35 mille dollars de frais à
l'automne plateau mont royal adopté un
nouveau règlement lorsque vous
démolissez plus de 35% des murs
extérieurs et du toit et que le plancher
est mise au niveau c'est l'équivalent de
démolir votre maison on dépasse le
critère des surfaces qui sont altérées
et tout à coup c'est comme si j'avais me
raser la maison une fois rénover votre
maison est donc considérée comme une
construction neuve des frais
s'appliquent notamment pour la création
de parcs comme si c'était une neuve
comme la perception c'est juste un moyen
détourné pour aller chercher des revenus
additionnels par l'arrondissement daniel
mayet n'est pas seul cette firme
d'architectes à une dizaine de clients
dans la même situation si jamais ses
règlements le 7 ans dans d'autres
quartiers
ça va toucher énormément de personnes le
maire de l'arrondissement dit qu'il est
ouvert à étudier les cas particuliers il
faut regarder les co-parrains mais en
même temps on peut pas modifier le
règlement pour un corps donc
cependant il insiste le règlement a été
adopté
justement pour protéger le
plateau-mont-royal des multiples
transformations la valeur des maisons
augmentent beaucoup trop rapidement avec
l'ancien règlement sur deux de
démolition et déjà qu'il gardait
seulement le plancher que la façade puis
là il construisait ce qu'il voulait des
fois deux fois plus gros daniel mayet
lui ne sait pas s'il fera quand même ces
travaux pour l'instant je n'ai aucune
idée je vois c'est ce qui est moyen de
modifier le plan de rénovation
il ne comprend pas pourquoi des élus qui
veulent garder la classe moyenne à
montréal ne les ai pas dans leurs
projets ici françois qu'hormis
radio-canada m'ont rien